very much welcome to the college
debrief we are today the 15th
of december i must say that the college
meeting is still ongoing so it is a
slightly special
readout that we're giving today but in
view of the importance of the subject
and your deadlines we have decided to
move forward i immediately passed the
floor
to executive president mrs vestrick well
good afternoon and welcome to the
college reach readout
we have actually not finished the
meeting but i would like to give you
still an overview of the points
that was discussed uh before moving to
the denser services act and the digital
markets act
we started our meeting today with an
exchange with
jen stoltenberg the secretary general of
nato
then the college discussed the new cyber
security strategy
together with proposals to enhance the
resilience
of key digital and physical entities
the new strategy will indeed bolster our
collective
resilience ben against cyber
threats and we have a lot of those so
about
time the proposals will be uh
presented by my colleagues joseph
burrell
margarita and chiri uh during a press
conference
uh tomorrow morning then
we discuss the action plan on tackling
non-performing loans
in the context of the kovite 19 pandemic
and what it does is that it puts forward
a range of measures
to address a renewed buildup of
non-performing loans
on bank's balance sheets after the kovit
19
pandemic this will enable banks
to continue lending to households and to
businesses
and of course by doing that to support
the economic recovery uh
executive vice president vladimirovsky
and commissioner mary mcginnis
they will be here in the press room to
present this action plan to you
tomorrow the president debriefed us
all on the european council that we
found to be successful
uh and as i speak now uh michel banyi is
depriving the college
on the state of play in the eu uk
negotiations
finally the commission has decided to
appoint
mr john watson as the new deputy
secretary general
and with this set please let me move to
uh
the proposals that chiri and myself are
presenting here
today because
what we are going to present to you are
two
milestones in our journey to make europe
fit
for digital age the digital services act
and the digital markets act
the two proposals they serve one purpose
to make sure that we as users as
customers
businesses have access to a wide
choice of safe products and services
online
just as well as we do in the physical
world
and that all businesses operating in
europe that can be big ones that can be
small
small ones that they can freely and
fairly compete
online just as they do offline because
this is one world whether from our
streets or from our screens we should be
able to do our shopping in a safe
manner whether we turn pages or we just
scroll down
we should be able to choose and to trust
the news
that we read and of course what is
illegal offline
is equally illegal online
i will say a few words about the the two
proposals
and and then of course today as well and
we hope to be able to take
uh questions uh and for you to to meet
your your deadlines
i've been wondering how to uh how to
give a metaphor because these are two
quite complex
proposals and and the best thing
i think i came to think of was the first
ever traffic light
uh that brought order in the streets
that was actually in the u.s in
cleveland ohio
and that was invented as a response to a
major technological
uh disruption the invention of the car
and i think just like back then it's
more than 100 years ago
now we have such an increase in the
online traffic that we need to make
rules that put order into chaos
and and that is what the digital service
act uh is all about
creating new rules uh making the online
world
a a safe reliable secure space for users
of digital roads because we should be
able to trust
what we see online to navigate without
being confronted with terrorist
propaganda and feeling certain that the
toy that we buy online
is safe just as well as the toy that we
buy in a brick and mortar shop
three main actions uh in uh in the
digital services act
more safety for users increasing
transparency of platforms
and better enforcement safety first
obviously
because a safe digital space is one that
protects users from illegal
and harmful content while preserving the
freedom of expression
and that is the very important balance
that we have been
keeping so
we introduce new due diligence uh
obligations
uh digital platforms will be required to
swiftly remove
illegal content but in parallel to
explain
why to the user
why the content was removed and give him
or her
a an option to complain about it
also the new obligation to know your
customer will require online
marketplaces
to check their seller's identity before
they are allowed on the platform which
will make it so much more difficult
for doctor dodgy traders to do their
business
then transparency
it's quite difficult to to realize to
see through
why you see this and not that why
is one seller right higher than another
um why do we get to see this first this
second and
maybe something not at all uh so the
digital services act will also require
platforms to tell us
how their algorithms work how their
recommender system
selects the content that they show us
but
not require platforms to reveal their
algorithms
but to give us a better idea of who's
trying to influence us
and give us a choice as to whether we
want to trust this
or not and last but not least
enforcement because no legislation is
any better
than the enforcement of it for people to
travel
safely well we need to have the same
rules across europe
this is why it's a regulation this is
why it's based on single market
legal basis and it needs to be tied
to possible sanctions we maintain the
country of oregon
principle that everyone knows so well
but member states will be much much
better equipped
to enforce that national laws
and the authorities that are to um
where the platforms are established well
they will be much better at imposing
redress
actions uh if a platform failed to
comply
so there will be a european approach to
having still the country of oregon
principle now turning to the digital
markets act
this is our second proposal and whether
digital service act
is horizontal applies to everyone well
the digital markets act applies is
specifically
to what we call gatekeepers and
gatekeepers
they are defined by a special role that
they fulfilled in the marketplace
a role defined by the size
the role they play and the durability in
the market
so first on size gatekeepers they are
large players in terms of annual
turnover
market capitalization and they are
active in several
member states second their role
that they are really operating as
gatekeepers
so that they are in between a large
number
of businesses and an even larger number
of individual users so they
play a special role for businesses
actually to get access to their
customers
and third the durability that they have
this
uh entrenched position over uh quite
some time
i think you can imagine how this
combination of criteria
can give gatekeepers an unfair advantage
in a given service and that is
very often an unbalanced relationship
and this is nothing new for us we have
seen this in
in numerous competition cases and this
was one of the reasons why we asked
three special advisors uh to prepare
sort of the thinking
how can we be better at dealing with
this unbalanced
relationship and one of the things they
they
suggested was indeed that vigilant
competition or enforcement
is combined with regulation
and as you will know from the casework
that the commission has been doing that
i have been responsible for
is not one it's not two it's three
google cases we've seen this behavior
it's the first amazon case concerning
ebooks now we have a second one
a third investigation ongoing national
authorities
they have been dealing with cases for
instance by by booking.com and
complaints keep coming
through our doors so we have many more
investigations right now
so obviously this is to complement
vigilant competition law enforcement
this is to do the same thing
as we have been doing in banking in
telecoms
in energy to realize that antitrust will
have to work hand in hand
with regulation so that we have a
complete set
of tools and then just what are
these tools well the tools are
uh actually uh quite simple because once
you're designated a gatekeeper
you will have to um
you will have to live up to a number of
obligations
and i will just name three the use of
data
interoperability and self-preferencing
the use of data a gatekeeper gathers
enormous amounts of data so they also
gather enormous insights
in the ups and downs of their competitor
they will know who buys what
when at what price how do they pay
they know if you hesitated or you went
straight uh to buy what you wanted
so the point is here to say that
gatekeepers shall no longer use
the data they collect from all
businesses that they host
when competing against them and that
would imply
data science that allow for the
separation of data
generated in the different business
lines
second interoperability
uh this concerns a situation where a
gatekeeper
is offering an extra service one example
could be
a gatekeeper developing a new payment
solution
that work with a piece of software and a
piece of hardware and maybe only making
it available
for its own payment solution
now the interoperability obligation well
that will say
well you you need to uh
to make it available also for others who
can compete with you
in providing this payment solution
finally self-preferencing because we
have seen platforms gatekeepers who who
treat their
own services more favorable than those
of their competitors
for instance by ranking their own
services higher
than their competitors and in doing that
attracting more users
so the point is here to oblige the
gatekeeper
to adjust the search algorithm to make
sure that rival offers
while they receive the same level of
provenance as their own office
would do in this proposal
there is a sense of future proofing
because it's also dynamic
we can do investigations uh if it need
be
so that we can see if gatekeepers are
emerging and we
can put them then obligations
and this is of course because without
enforcement
not worth much and here again if a
gatekeeper
breaks the rules we can impose fines if
it's done
several times repeatedly we can also
impose
structural remedies divestiture that
sort of
things and as that's this is a
complement to competition law
enforcement
it is somewhat complex but we're looking
very much forward
i know uh the level of complexity
because it has taken the two of us
to get it done and many many people are
in our services
so it is with some level of well maybe
not pride but thankfulness
uh that we stand here today julie
thank you very much thank you so much
margaret it has been uh
it has been an unbelievable journey that
uh that uh we had to go through
together with myself and our teams over
the past year
unbelievable journey but here we are
today and you just all remember that uh
um our president uh lion
asked us both of us to uh to come back
as soon as possible
with a new proposal she said it would be
great if you can do it
in 2020 we are the 15th of december
here we are here we are together and
that's true
that's very important so i will be short
and i would like to because margaret
said already almost
everything and i know that you are also
a technical briefing this morning but uh
i i i just wanted to tell you in few
words
what are these two act and what
there are not and by the way also maybe
a little bit of internal cooking
how we have been able to do it so i will
start budgeting cooking
uh we we we had a lot a lot of
interactions
with margaret and myself our teams i
would like to mention also the uh of
course the president
she was extremely involved in it a
cabinet or staff
but also a lot of external stakeholders
because this is a very important
subject for all of us and everyone
has something to say our children
our companies our governments
the un the ngos of course the
parliaments
and believe me the parliament is really
on it
i'm going to say the parliament is of
course the open parliament but but the
parliament for all our 27 member states
and and and we decided margaret and
myself that
we spend the first half of the year
while listening to these
uh stakeholders and we have asked
all these stakeholders to come back to
us with their
ideas request fears
hope ambitions and they answered
massively three thousand answers
contributions
that's huge two thirds coming from
europe from everybody
one third coming from outside of the eu
believe me everyone answered and we took
the time
margaret and myself including by the way
during the summer time
to look at it of course we will not make
everybody happy
but we took our decision we as we are a
political body
and it's our role to take political
decisions this is exactly what we are
presenting
to you today what it is not
which this is not and we will never say
here
either myself of course margaret neiser
we believe that
this company or that company are too big
we don't say that here in europe
we respect companies but we say that the
bigger they are
the more obligations they may have to
fulfill
what is important to us in other words
what it is
is to give clarity to give visibility
to give objectives everybody is welcome
in europe but
our responsibility is to decide and to
give
the directions and the rules just to
protect what is important to us
in other words this is not two acts
where we will say or this company is too
big we will propose a dismantlement
not here not on this side of the ocean
you will never hear either migrating
myself to say that
this is again not against it is
for it is for european citizens it is
for our democracy
it is for our companies it is for
innovations
it is for fair competition it not
against anybody
so this being said i just would like to
to say of course that
with regulations as margaret said
you need to have also sanctions we hope
of course that we will not
uh we will not have to
this is really something different
because of course another dma
it's a regulation excellente and we have
a lot of discretion
i understand that in other countries or
continent they will stick
only to the pure competition rules for
us we decided based
of course of the experience already in
this in this house another
market leadership that we had to take
maybe another approach
with an excellente to be quick and fast
because we know that in the digital
space digital is fair
speed is of the essence and we need to
act quickly
because if we don't act quickly we may
then disturb concurrence
and and destroy opportunities for uh for
some players
who could if not could have been
successful innovators
and this is why here we have also some
different criterias of course
and of course different obligations
excellente and the quaters as my god
said as
the size and we define the size by of
course revenue but we know of students
in the 21st century
revenue are linked also with market
power or fair market value this is why
we have an ore certain level of revenue
or
a specific market value by the way you
see that the market
the market value fair market value is
roughly 165
billion this is what is written in the
document you will have it represents
just to give you an id if you take your
stock euro stock 50
the average market value of the 50
biggest companies in europe is roughly
55 56 billion so it means that you
belong to
the first half of the 50
largest company in europe which is
already quite successful
and of course and we encourage this but
bigger size bigger responsibility
i don't want to be too good to be more
wrong we will have also in terms of
condition of course the number of
for dma the number of customers
same thing if it's
b2c 10 of the european population
and if it's b2b 10 000 uh of these
customers
so that's we believe a very very uh
balanced approach
very clear with with with clear
obligations
again everybody will be welcome we will
just
organize ourselves so that we we hope
to be one of the most active uh digital
market in the world
while respecting everything which is
important to us that i just mentioned
thank you very much thank you very much
to both of you for these introductions
let's move to the questions and answer
session
we have interpretation to remind you in
german english
french italian danish spanish
and international sign and we will go
immediately to the floor
and i give the thought to matisse
hi my name is mata schiffers has
finished here
from the netherlands i have a question
for commissioner festa
what is the main reason that the college
meeting took so long today
and i'm asking this because there have
some been quite some rumors that there
are quite some different opinions
on the dsa and the dma within the the
college not the lease between
you and mr breton is there any merit in
these rumors or can you put them
too bad and the second question is
regarding
the sanctions the six to ten percent i
read in the documents is that of total
sales of company global sales or
european sales because i'm
hearing some different views on that
well thank you very much um
it was a very good college uh i think we
spent the first two hours with uh nato's
secretary general ian stoltenberg
the first time ever that a nature
general secretary actually
visits us the the college of the
european uh union
uh and then we discussed a number of
other things
actually i don't know if i say too much
i was a bit disappointed
that we didn't have more time for the
digital services act and the digital
markets act
because as i think it is obvious we have
put a lot of effort
into these two proposals so that was not
the case
i have also uh well it's maybe it's too
much to say that it's rumors i have i
have read an article about the
differences between tyrion myself
uh i think they are obvious i can
confirm that we are different people
uh i also can confirm that we have
discussions
and i think that is what leads to a good
strong proposals
and this is why we're here today if we
were the same
well i think our president would have to
put something
else down in in the boil in the
in the bowel actually to make it cook
and to produce something of value
so uh so in that respect uh i think you
can you can rest assured
that something is true yes we're
different but something is true as well
this is our common proposal and this
is by the entire commission uh on the
question of
fines it is indeed six percent in the
digital services act
and 10 in the digital markets act it is
article
26 and it is uh uh
10 of its total turnover each
undertaking
the total turnover in the preceding
financial year
just one word first one of course mark i
say everything i don't have anything to
add
if maybe when somebody thinks when we
come to college
politically of course everything is
already stabilized because there's
already our discretion between
us and of course including with our with
our cabinet and
we have many many internal discretions
for four months so uh this is
absolutely not returned to the length of
this college we had so many subjects
so that's just to answer your question
and i fully conclude
of course with what magata said the
second one of course is
the six and ten percent is for global
turnover which is important
not only european class thank you
we go to silvia now
sylvia go ahead yes can you hear me yeah
okay
um thank you so much for your time um i
have two questions
one um when would you like to see these
rules
adopted do you think this could actually
be sooner than usual when it comes to
how fast european european union
implements laws
and then a second question and some of
your work in the past
has seen some backlash in particular
from the united states
i was just wondering if you're expecting
that sort of backlash once again
or whether the conversations that you
might have with your u.s colleagues has
been
slightly different to this time thank
you very much to both
well we've been as julie said
initially we've been working very much
with both the european parliament and
with member states
uh i was in in the european parliament
when there was a debate about the
their own initiative reports more than
60 members of parliament took the floor
a lot of interest and and i think you'd
see
also that a lot of what we have put in
here also is
answering some of the asks from the
european parliament so of course we hope
that it can be as fast as possible i
still think that fast in in
in this connection is year and a half
give or take
and then another six months for the
regulation uh actually to take effect
uh then there will be uh some back and
forth uh for the
digital markets act about who to be
designated
uh gatekeeper but i still think that we
quite
fast actually can have uh results from
this obviously we are eager
uh to work with member states in
parliament to make it even faster
so i don't think that it will depend on
us uh on the question
of the us
when i first came into the the job as
commissioner for for competition
uh of course i was traveling the us i
was visiting uh
colleagues and also both sides of the
aisle
going up and down the hill and that was
a different world
uh completely different world they were
kind of what are you doing in europe
now the u.s us
the australians uh the canadians the
japanese
uh pa is part of a global conversation
about
how to how to balance things because the
important thing here is
with size comes responsibility and and i
think
with the sort of preparedness coming
from
uh us reaching out for the eu us
partnership obviously pandemic first
then climate change
but also focusing on digital errors
there are no surprises here
for our u.s colleagues uh of course
to some degree they will see things
differently because it's another market
and another nation but i think the
debate will be very different
than if we have taped this five years
ago
that's a very important question because
of course timing is everything
but we are democracy and by the way the
u.s also our big democracy
it takes time in a democracy to have
this kind of huge act to be adopted and
we have to respect the time of democracy
but as margaret said we prepared
extremely well i think
ourselves in the enormous interaction
that we had of course with member states
and with the parliament
by the way a lot of member parliament
worked worked extremely well and gave us
a lot of ideas and input
and we put this again in this
two act so yes we will respect this
hopefully we'll be able to start as
early as as a
as a very soon uh early next year
but i just wanted to tell you to say a
few things first
it's not a directive it's a regular
which means that we will be able to
apply it
very quickly this is also one of the
reasons and autonomous
homogenously all over europe that's
another reason why we selected this
second thing three months application
for the dsa
six months for the dma so as soon as it
will be in place
we can move very quickly third and this
is something that i wanted to share with
you
we have been in interactions almost on a
daily basis
with all the big platforms by the way
some of these big platforms will belong
to the to the categories
that we uh described migration myself
as a systemic platforms or gatekeepers
and every time
and especially during the crisis and use
the first
wave of the crisis we request we said
hey
be careful you have to correct this too
many hat speeches
you have to be careful with your
outgoing and i should tell you because
i i have been engaging with them for
most of them
they understood and they tried to move
and we said you know
we will do it at the end of the year by
the way it will happen
it will happen maybe in six months in
one year and by the way
this is something that you need to
anticipate and guess what a lot of these
platforms
already anticipated what we discussed
with them
and i am a strong believer also of soft
governance
because at the end of the day we believe
that
uh with a systemic players or or vedic
platforms
the bigger you are the more
responsibility you have with a visa
society
and they understand that and they need
to have what we believe
is a good behavior for us european so of
course
we will have on one hand on one hand the
law
okay is
italian radio first question to vice
president the stagger and it will not be
on italia very easy how many
european companies will be defined as
gatekeepers or systemic
platforms in question
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
well we've been discussing back and
forth uh this question about
whether or not to name the companies
that we think
comes within these uh presumption as
siri mentioned
a eu turnover of 6.5 billion or
average market capitalization of 65
billion being present in at least
three member states with one uh core
platform service
45 million active users per month
a 10 000 yearly business users per month
um and we've been going back and forth
because
here we lay out uh some objective
criteria
that sort of translates the requirements
of of size
and and being an important gateway
uh and having a durability and and we
decided to say well it is for the
companies themselves
to identify uh because it's
it may be market sensitive it may also
be that they
they're in in two or of the criteria or
three of the criteria
but not in all of the criteria uh if
they are not in
in all of the criteria then eventually
we may do an investigation to see if
it's an emergent
emerging uh gatekeeper but also it's for
them to to
rebut uh these assumptions of being a
gatekeeper
uh and this is why i think it would be
premature for us here to say well it's
that and that's on that platform and
definitely not those in those and those
um so that will remain to be seen
foreign
online
[Music]
[Music]
the vice president uh i was wondering
you know uh with these uh dsa and dma
rules
uh what about your ongoing empty trust
cases for example into amazon and google
and facebook
do you see that the concluding before
the rules are in place or
will be the other way wrong or conclude
at the same time thank you
what we are suggesting here is without
prejudice
both to 101 and 102 and actually
there's also some room for uh for
national
uh competition legislation uh of course
you cannot sort of undermine
either the digital services act or due
to marcus act but actually you can do
more
so we can continue uh the cases that
we're doing and we will indeed
uh continue uh the cases and of course
we will do our best
to finalize those uh as fast as possible
you know we just sent the statement of
objection to to amazon
while opening another amazon case
the apple cases are also quite advanced
so of course we will continue doing our
job
because the people depending on on a
solution
on on those issues they shall not wait
for these regulations to come in place
thank you we move now to matthew matthew
newman
mike source matthew
yeah can you hear me okay sorry about
that
so uh commissioner um bestair i wanted
to ask um
well either for either of you actually i
want to take the question
um it's about the digital services act
and uh as you know the um most of these
big u.s tech companies are based have
their main establishment
in ireland and i understand very well
that the regulation uh clearly states
that the
national competition national
authorities need to have
um the authority to to enforce the
regulation
so my question is about the enforcement
structure do you expect that
for the very large uh companies the very
large platforms
that um ireland will um get
most of the investigations most of the
complaints
uh similar to what's going on data
protection
regulation um or do you expect because
the rules are
written the way that most of these
pan-european services are are by the the
the big tech companies the large
platforms and it's actually the european
commission
that will take the bulk complaints the
bulk of the
investigations and where does that leave
the member states if
if they have issues with these large
companies
thanks very much
well i think sort of the state of play
is a
rather complicated relationship between
country of origin and a number of member
states
there's been some robust exchanges so to
speak
um not all probably well a lot can be
said about this
the the new situation will be that here
there is a number of things that are
clearly uh to be enforced
uh these things are new so we're coming
from a situation
where there weren't that many rules
actually very few
to a situation where you have a clear
framework as to what has to be enforced
and that is uh then for uh the country
of origin
uh for the main bulk park of that but
for the country of destination of
services
both they can have their own national
services and they of course can
ask the country of origin to do the job
of enforcing these rules if that is not
happening and here we are suggesting
timelines deadlines as to when it should
happen then eventually
the commission can take over and
actually do it
and this is this is to make a new
balance between the the
country of origin and the country of
destination
of services and of course we hope that
over time
this will build a renewed trust between
member states
that this is something that we do
together and the second thing
that i would like to mention is of
course that we're talking a lot about
the big ones
but as it is now we have quite a degree
of fragmentation
between different national rules in
these areas
and that can make it very difficult for
a small company actually to scale
because you have to figure out what is
the rules here what are the rules there
what is the rules in the third place
now when it is a regulation and it will
be
the same rules well then you can just
focus on your scaling up and not to have
lawyers to work in figuring out
what is actually is that we want to do
so there is a very
positive side effect for smaller
businesses being able to scale up in a
real digital single market
if i may say so it's not like for gdpr
and and this is why i think it is really
something specific
first you could settle everywhere you
want
it will be the same everywhere
everywhere in europe
it would be the same you you will have a
local authority
and and this local authority will have
to uh to act
uh when there is something happening on
the network either in the country of
origin or country destination
and as margaret said the commission
will monitor all this and will be will
be able to to to issue
for my if you might mess with me a sort
of a
european digital warrant to act
immediately
so that's really the way the way it will
work and by the way
uh um again this is something very
important for all the platforms
you are speaking about big platforms but
including the new one
or including very big platforms uh which
were operating in the in the eu
without having a legal representative
there will have an obligation
to have a legal representant in europe
but of course the principle of
choosing the country where you want to
settle
will belong to the platforms thank you
we move to catherine fury
hello
we've lost you catherine can you start
over please
oops yep no
sorry for this our daily bread
catherine yeah go ahead
no yeah no it's working go ahead
grab the opportunity okay
all right so uh my question is
uh you you said uh commissioner breton
that you want
uh your open market
um where everybody is welcome and
from what i see you've taken in the past
it's been
uh sort of a presumption of innocence
you could say for the gaffa
um where uh sort of wait and see what
happens and then test them through
competition rules etc um and yet
other players particularly in the asian
market have been
uh there's been a presumption of guilt
in some sense
will these will this these proposals
re rebalance this uh
this approach and uh create a level
playing field
and you've also spoke about an ecosystem
a fair uh free and fair competition
ecosystem and
uh as was already been mentioned you
know people like
uh companies like amazon their average
tax is 9.5
uh retail on the streets which is under
huge pressure
at the moment is 23.2 on average
but that's not free and fair competition
and by
dividing up the the digital and the
normal market
you're still not addressing this
imbalance
no but but i think catherine uh we we
regulate
again for a level playing field i think
that's very important to understand that
uh so that all businesses will have
the same opportunities no matter the
nationality this is really something
which is important we also have
civil law and that does not presuppose
guilt of course
just clear rules for everyone as i
uh said at the beginning we are not
targeting
anybody uh in dma we have
just based again our approach on
objective criteria and that's it
so uh so i think this is very clear and
and
and again i know that in some other uh
part of the of the world
they have a different approach for us
this is our approach this is why we say
it's a level playing field
and by the way including which is very
important for us
within the internal market
you want to add a word yeah well
sort of the idea is to say we can we can
from our experience from
the special advisors from from others
who have been looking into this
we can see that there are companies who
play a very special role in the
marketplace
because of their size because
they are intermediaries between other
businesses and customers or users
because they have been there for quite
some time and
and we then translate this
role into what you could call rebuttable
presumptions and then it is for for
business to say
um am i am i within this framework
if i am well then i will have to do
these things
and not to do these things and that is
of course a reflection both of the
experience from competition law
but also going beyond competition law
into what you could call
unfair trading practices and and
bringing some order
uh in the digital space i mentioned this
traffic light that
came on uh more than a hundred years ago
that was sort of the first thing
to make some order in digital space and
of course i do hope that
as we move forward uh sort of it will be
a norm
that everyone will respect what is green
and what is red
so that we get a different marketplace
because for instance this example that i
took
about the use of data that you cannot
use the data
of the people that you compete with just
because you can
no you have to make sure that you use
data silo so that you have your own
data and the people that you compete
with they have their own data
and that creates fairness in the
marketplace because if you have
everybody's data well then the risk you
run is very very low because
you can easily predict what people want
and what they want to pay
if you have none or only very few data
you have a much higher risk
and that is also part of fair
competition that everyone will have to
do their own assessment about what works
in the marketplace
not that being completely unlevel
because some have access to all the data
or in the example of interoperability
that if you are a gatekeeper and you
produce an extra service
that others are actually allowed to
compete with you because they can also
interoperate
with uh the core service that you're
providing and that is also a very
important element
of fair competition and this is why this
will work
to level the playing field this will not
solve everything like this
and there will be many other issues and
taxation is indeed one of them
but it's a it's a fair step
on a long road to make sure that all
businesses no matter
their size have a fair chance of
reaching potential customers
thank you we move to mark scott
good afternoon everybody have a couple
questions just in terms of within the
commission who is going to determine
who is and who is not a gatekeeper and
per the proposals is it fair to say that
companies like facebook google amazon
and apple will fall into that definition
second question is in terms of next
steps
where do you see the toughest
negotiation now that the proposals are
heading both to
parliament and council thank you
well once the regulation is
adopted it will come into effect after
six months
then it is for uh for businesses sort of
to to notify themselves or to say well
it may seem as if we're part of this but
we think we're not and then the
commission will have some time to say
well we think actually you're in scope
for for these do's and don'ts
or you're not uh or to sort of
investigate further to say we have to
think that you're an emerging gatekeeper
so we will have this more sort of
tailor-made approach as to how to make
sure that competition can actually work
freely also in the market where you have
a strong position
and that is for the commission uh to do
that but it will be sort of with these
reputable uh presumptions so that the
businesses
uh will of course have uh a say and they
will have
you know all the the necessary and and
obviously a hundred percent legitimate
uh guarantees when it comes to the legal
procedures
uh when it comes to sort of next steps
in in the negotiation
i think that is very difficult to say uh
because
i think if you if you go through the the
european parliament reports
you'd find things there which are not in
here you'll find things in here that are
not
in the european parliament reports as
same goes for the member states but
those who have legislation already and
those who consider
legislation we have been trying to find
a balance
to reach this very basically simple goal
of making sure that offline and online
merges
um not only what is illegal online is
also illegal offline
other way around but also what is legal
offline is also legal online and i think
here there will be
quite a number of debates but of course
that remains to be seen and i'd say that
we are ready
excellent thank you we move to natalie
mcnellis
natalie
hello can you hear me yes go ahead
natalie yes
okay great i my question is for uh
executive vice president vester please
um i had a question about murder control
there's been often a lot of complaints
saying that
gatekeepers like these shouldn't have
ever been allowed
to have certain acquisitions you know
facebook shouldn't have been able to get
whatsapp or
instagram and i'm wondering is there
something
here in this dma that helps you to deal
with that problem with the problem of
like
killer acquisitions um is there
something new here
for merger control can you block things
that you couldn't have blocked otherwise
can you ask for more conditions than you
couldn't have asked
thanks what is in here
is a an obligation to notify if you
acquire
a smaller company that will not meet the
murder thresholds
as you will probably know we have been
working with this for quite some time
in order to make sure that we will
actually see these acquisitions
so this is one of the things that we do
we ask for a notification
if if one of the the companies in the
scope
of this legislation if if they acquire a
smaller company
but we'll also proceed on the work uh
that we're doing with
um with member states in order to have
the national competition authorities
to notify us if they see something in
the marketplace and they wonder
shouldn't someone look at this much
closer
obviously we develop our analysis
and in here there is there is
no sort of uh new uh
merger criteria uh but obviously
we will keep looking if a acquisition
sort of makes
a position more entrenched if it raises
barrier to entry
uh that sort of issues as we have done
in
in the different cases that we actually
have seen because they have been
referred to us
maybe if you allow me of course
we are not here to to to to block
business
we are just here to organize ourselves
and what is very new as margaret said
is that we will be able to be informed
and we will make sure if you take the
example that you mentioned i don't
i don't i don't name any company on
stage but you're the one who is now
under scrutiny
on the other side of the ocean
i mean at the beginning nobody thought
that it could
become what it is today and then
four five years six years later they
realize and they decide they have to
take action
for us if a gatekeeper
wants to make an acquisition you can do
it for free of course
you will notify us and we are also
i mean we are watching that we will have
we will just watch on a regular basis
what's happening and if we we we
discover because we will be able to
follow
what's happening asking also companies
if we
if we discover that in the stage of
evolution
because of this acquisition it hits
our criteria of the dna we will act
and then we will not have to wait until
it happens but by the way it could be a
very
another very smart acquisition which
will help business help innovation and
so on
just again an ability to monitor
what's happening that's it but it's
already important
thank you we moved to alexander fanta
alexander hey alexander
try again
but that's refreshing with an empty
shelf you should use
people to send all their books
on modern capitalism um
my question can you hear me yes we can
hear you and
we're having a bit of fun sorry alex
my my question concerns the
interoperability of services the
dma states that gatekeeper platforms
should allow business users and
providers of auxiliary services to
access and uh interoperability with
their services which would potentially
as i understand it paved the way
for instance the commission to tell
whatsapp to make
its service interoperable with other
messaging services
could you explain a bit how that works
and particularly
my question would be whether the
commission um or
whether that could entail the commission
telling
services like whatsapp to introduce
backdoors to encryption for law
enforcement
oh wow that was that was tricky
oh and a number of things at the same
time
it's not a given that interoperability
uh
well well
no i actually i don't know uh because
the point of interoperability is that
you if you have a core platform service
can be a social network can be an
operating system
if you then uh put on another an extra
service
in my example here a payment service
could also be a marketplace
well then you have to allow for others
also to
compete against you with a payment
service or with a marketplace
so in that respect that other services
can interoperate
with your core platform service uh
in these different respects um i don't
know how that will
deal with sort of more criminal uh
investigations
uh we have sort of very carefully uh
been been weighing out here
uh to say well what what uh what rules
should there be if
for instance uh some of the uh things
that are seen online
are criminal uh that there is a risk of
the the safety of
individuals uh that then you can
actually take down
a service uh for a certain time while
it's investigated
uh and also since you you have this
for for sort of less damaging or at
least not
uh criminal in that respect uh illegal
uh content
that when you take it down and you have
to alert those that
were the original authors of the
material
that it has been taken down then you
have to maintain it for some time
and here it may be that the police i
don't know what
but at least you cannot just throw it
out immediately
because you need to alert the people who
actually uh put it up in the first place
uh but this has not been sort of the
main scope
of this regulation whatsoever so it's
just a
a test of giving you at least part of a
response to what you're asking
if i if i say alexander i remember very
well
if i can have the microphone i remember
very well that you asked that question
last week during the press conference
with vice president skinass
and commissioner johansson on the
security union
elements that were presented last week
you got uh you got a precise answer from
commissioner johansson last week on that
very specific question
uh so clearly these are different
subjects um that we are dealing with
today interoperability is really
something
which is in the in in the dsa and that's
that's very important underneath what
what what we said that interoperability
measures will have to be ensured
by the platform themselves and of course
we will check
if they are effective so we will give us
the the means to to be able to check
that they put in place
interoperability by the way what will be
the case you remember
for the telco uh universe so as we will
just check they do this properly
and you're right eric encryption is
totally out of the scope
but you may find again some specific
rules in
specific sectoral legislation that we
may plug
in like for example terrorism or other
things
but not in the transversal again
regulation that we propose today thank
you
we now move to louise
hello and thank you for this briefing um
a question on the dsa there's an
argument that you're trying to pull a
lot of different activities here in the
same regulation
i mean that the question of regulating
hate speech is different from
dangerous toys which is different again
from cosmetics
and maybe it would be a better idea to
instead of regulating sort of all these
business models together you should
regulate activity so that
the people selling toys should be under
the same rules whether it's online or
offline
what do you say to this whole strain of
argument thank you
well to some degree they are under the
same rules because the rules concerning
the toy
well these are the same rules what it
especially cannot uh have as
a content and and what is illegal
uh when it comes to for instance child
pornography or child abuse
terrorist content bomb recipes that is
illegal end of story
what we are doing here is to make sure
that you can actually
get rid of it that's the point and that
is exactly
why it's about how the services are
provided
uh the know you customer obligation you
should know who's putting things up for
sale here
because what what we have i think
numerous examples of
is that people who sell dangerous stuff
they are taken down and then boof
you have them back again because the
platform doesn't know them sufficiently
so they cannot make sure that this
doesn't happen
and when it comes to to content it's
basically the same thing you need to to
do the due diligence
so that if for instance a trusted
flagger says well this is this shouldn't
be here it's illegal
that you actually there to take it down
because what is illegal
is the same thing it is national
legislation it's in european legislation
it's in in the different demands
on products that is the same this is
about how the services they are
performed
and i i think as we said at the
beginning
what is the dsr what is not the dsa the
dsa
do not regulate content
the dsa just give obligations
so we do not regulate content just
vertical legislation that we you may
plug in
will have their own requirements
both in term by the way of
sanction and also action by
the platforms and we will make sure that
in these regulations
that membership may do that maybe the
way you may do
will make sure that your platforms are
have
well put in place the tools to do it
but again it's not about regulating
content
okay if you have time we still have four
questions um we will now move to naomi
oh thank you very much for taking my
question um so just
quickly um we mentioned a little bit
about irish
regulatory powers today we had the first
fine
of under gdpr of one of the tech
companies only 450
000 euros some four years after the
offense is that's
like meaningful at all for a company
that has a turnover of 3.5 billion
and does that bode well for
implementation of these new rules
and then if you could comment more
generally on if you think that
regulatory powers in ireland is
sufficient
given their huge responsibilities on
behalf of the eu thank you
you want well well i i shall not make
any judgment when it comes to gdpr
and how that was how that was done the
point is here to say well here you have
enforceable rules and you have fines
uh up till six percent of global
turnover
in digital services act up till 10 in
the digital markets act
so you have a fine range uh that is
substantial
and you have a mechanism that makes sure
that no authority
is left behind that should be more often
a european anthem
i think no authority left behind in
order to be able to do that job
and here each national authority no
matter where a platform
registers themselves will be in a
network with
the host countries and with the
commission on board
so so we have been trying to think how
to make an
efficient efficient system while making
sure that we can preserve the country of
oregon principle
because that is very efficient when you
want one digital single market
that you can just register one place and
again
i think this is very important also for
smaller businesses
because if you want to scale your
business it's a good thing that oh
you're
you're registered where is your home
where you sort of started your business
and you don't have to do more and here
again you don't have to
employ lawyers to sort of try to figure
out what are the rules in the next
market national market where you want to
go
so so this is the balancing act here to
make it simple
also for the smaller ones who want to
scale up while at the same time making
the
enforcement system more efficient
this is different from gdpr and i think
it's important to repeat it
just to highlight also your your
question
our approach of fine is a proportionate
graduate
and deterrent if it's necessary and this
means that
we we have a toolbox beyond uh financial
fines object objectives that's uh
the only thing that that that we have uh
we will put
forward again a european uh mechanism
which we believe will be efficient but
again it is really different
from the gdpr strategy
thank you we moved to samuel samuel
sultan
thank you very much can you hear me okay
yeah go ahead
go ahead good stuff thank you um i'd
just like to know what exactly happened
with the original idea behind the new
competition tool
and the previous goal there was to be
able to intervene
in tipping markets or even detect signs
of tipping markets
and secondly uh there are reports
recently
that suggest the commission will soon
approve the acquisition of fitbit by
google
if that acquisition goes ahead further
down the line
how would the dma when eventually
adopted impact
future business practices as part of
acquisitions such as these
thank you
as you said uh we consulted on what we
call the new competition tool
uh and got a lot of different feedback
as julie also said numerous times
we got a lot of feedback what we decided
uh was to to create what we then decided
to call the digital markets act
uh so our thinking developed uh from the
consultation
into the proposal that we have tabled
today
and sort of the original idea of the of
the new competition tool
has been folded in in the digital
markets act to say well
we have this starting point where
gatekeepers can be designated
then they have to do the do's and not do
the don'ts
but the dynamic come from the idea of a
new competition tool
because we can do investigations we can
do investigations of course both to see
if they live up to what they should
but also do investigations to see well
what are emerging gatekeepers
and and what sort of tailor-made sets of
obligations
should they live up to and that is
exactly to make sure that we don't have
the tipping and markets
the tipping of a market that creates
another gatekeeper that would then fall
into the first
uh category and and that for us of
course is is important because that
gives a dynamic
also it it gives us a dynamic that can
improve
the denser markets act eventually with
the different do's and don'ts
but also to prevent that we get a series
of uh of tipping markets here that is
was the original idea
and now we have folded that in into the
markets act
on the second question you know i don't
comment on on ongoing
cases again uh one of the things that
will be important
is that if you are a gatekeeper and you
have a core
uh platform service then
if you compete with others in in sort of
extra services
uh next to that you will have to provide
interoperability you will have to make
it possible
for others to compete against you in
these extra
services or extra markets so that others
actually have a fair chance
of competing against you maybe one word
eric if you if you follow me
we thought really a lot uh uh and we
decided as a marketer said to to take
the best from the two ids
the empower of of excellent and the
flexibility of market investigation and
i think this is really
again uh what why is maybe uh
new and original because we were looking
again at the experience
and also being able to act quickly
for the second question i mean uh
uh of course if this is a goalkeeper we
will monitor the gatekeeper
and uh and and we will we will have of
course all informations
to see what's happening with this
acquisition and then we will follow
and if we realize that there's something
wrong like an
economic strengths
which we believe could create some
damages uh some um
user lock-in i don't know any kind of
things which which are again
in the dma which is happening now
because of this acquisition
then we will we will enforce and uh and
we will ask
to correct and if they don't correct we
have all the good actions
of our sanctions that's it thank you we
moved to
tebow
let's see just a reminder it's on dsidma
if not
can i ask the question go ahead
um so i understand that today's
initiative is
very much about preventing very large
platform from undermining fundamental
rights and arming the marketplace
but what about member states which means
huge competition rules to
undermine fundamental rights and distort
the marketplace i think about
budapest who keeps favoring
pro-governmental
media by giving most of the public
subsidies
they change merger rules to do that
there's a state a case from 2016 i
understand too
but that but this there's also poland
you just allowed the merger between
allen and lotus to
to to go ahead they argued that they
would be in position to invest in the
green deal and the first
big investment they make is to buy the
biggest polish press group
putting press freedom in danger
according to the first reactions
available so can you tell us what you
have done so far to prevent hungary from
misusing competition and stated policy
to distort the market for news and
research freedom of expression
can you commit to use your enforcement
powers to ensure that poland and hungary
do not get rid of the pre-free press by
misusing competition policy
and would you be up to championing media
markets act
listing do's and don'ts to prevent
states from meddling with the free press
thank you very much uh i think the rules
are clear this is a press conference on
the college readout
and on the proposals on dsa and dma
that have been made today and despite
the really big interest of your
questions they're out of scope of
today's press conference so
with my apologies we will move to the
last question today
from jacob perry
good evening commissioner executive vice
president uh jacob perry from par
just a question on whether there's been
any reflection on what might be the
institutional location of the unit
responsible for overseeing the dna
is that uh been reflected on yet or is
that to come for a later
day and then another follow-up question
just on
how the dna will interact with article
102
that phrase without prejudice perhaps
you could put it into layman's terms
will there be any uh structures on the
commission when it comes
to deciding on how it will use
article 102 and the dma thank you
well yes we have the intention of having
the commission
to do with the dma and the second
question
without prejudice to or 1010102 means
that of course 101 and 102 can be
enforced
whenever there is a case and that of
course is is what will have to be the
balancing act
because as you will have seen from some
different do's and don'ts
a lot of them are actually informed by
cases that we've had previously
uh in the google cases the first amazon
case
so of course we will be very careful to
see if
uh someone is complaining uh towards
someone
uh who is designated a gatekeeper uh if
that has to do with
uh sort of the do's and don'ts in there
or maybe it's a new behavior
uh by what could then be a dominant
company so so that will have to
be uh completely integrated uh in the
way that the dma
will be uh will be enforced uh how we
can do that both when it comes to issues
of dominant position
but also when it comes to businesses
actually meeting up
and in doing that disturbing the market
as in as in 101
but that is for the future uh to see how
it develops
i personally think that we will still
have plenty of
102 cases and that will then inform sort
of future versions of the digital
uh markets act uh because um
well it has developed just in in the
years that i've been here
and and the commission will uh will uh
enforce and
and and as soon as uh everything will be
done
uh believe me we will be
at the rendezvous
merci beaucoup participation thank you
very much for your participation
and see we have another press event now
technical briefing on non-performing
loans so please stay connected
thank you very much for your attention
you